to mozambique now and the latest in the
fight against a brutal insurgency at
least 3 000 people have been killed
there and about 750 000 have been
displaced in the three-year insurgency
now it all began when militants who call
themselves ansar al-suna attacked the
port city of mossimboa in late 2017.
then this july 1000 rwandan soldiers
began operations in mozambique well
skies africa correspondent john sparks
is with the rwandan military and reports
now from the province of cabo delgado
[Music]
the war on terror is moving to africa
and these soldiers from rwanda are
trying to raise morale
we'll never back down from the fight
they sing
and that's exactly what they want to
hear in mozambique where they have
struggled to cope with a vicious islamic
insurgency
salvation has appeared in the form of
paul kagame rwanda's longtime
authoritarian leader he's deployed one
thousand troops in what may be a long
and costly fight
one life lost
no time to stop for lunch replied the
mozambican president who seemed relieved
to have the rwandans there
mozambique's poorly trained army was
routed by the insurgents retreating or
fleeing from key communities in the
region of cabo delgado
but the involvement of the rwandans who
arrived in july
has turned this conflict around
in these pictures obtained exclusively
by sky news rwandan forces confront
insurgents in the forest around the
village of nakatengi
dozens of militants were killed in this
battle claims rwanda while others
escaped into the bush
the assault a key step in liberating the
port city of moisimba de pryor
[Applause]
the trauma caused by this three-year
insurgency
is hard to accept or understand
at a shelter we met a mother who said
she'd been enslaved by militants for
over a year
she escaped with her son during the
fighting
275 other women by the insurgents
i think that you are very brave
[Music]
also made her escape
but she almost died along with her son
as they tried to get away from the
insurgents
[Music]
[Music]
the leaders of this new coalition no
mozambique cannot fight the war on
terror alone
and president kagame seemed to
acknowledge this reality
president kagame
what's your exit plan because you can't
stay here forever you've said that it is
a costly operation
they need it to stay and for how long
that comes out naturally as
progress is made
we change forms of
things we are doing
so that we are very free and flexible
[Music]
that's a deep and open-ended commitment
to fight in mozambique
and if the rwandans don't who will the
americans and the british haven't
offered
but the threat posed by islamic
insurgents is fast expanding in africa
and the consequences can wear a country
down
john sparks sky news in cabo delgado